I didn't like it it came on by accident
the man looked like he was hurting her
he was holding her down and she was
screaming the reactions of children
exposed to porn too young one of my
friends have started treating women like
he's seen in the videos not major just a
slap here or there
Thanks everywhere there's like loads of
kids can find it well you can just go on
internet it not changes the way we just
got people acting relationships and
stuff as well they have to do something
that's unreal expectations and what it
is and what on the relationship as well
they're all pretty much perfect people
and it does make us feel more insecure
about everything did any of you think
that there are people who are getting
pressured into having sex because of
things they've seen on porn or some
people could have wanted to wait until
they felt they were ready that's they're
in a relationship when they're younger
they might feel like pressured into
doing it because it's sort of like
expected nowadays at a younger age it's
not just the fact that children are
being exposed to emulating what they see
from normalized violence fun healthy
ideas about relationships and exposure
to porn is increasingly landing young
people in courts the level of sexual
assaults feels like it's increasing
people think that the kind of things
children are doing to each other are
more serious than they used to be and
one can't help but feel that's because
these children have got access to this
kind of behavior on phones unregulated
access they're showing each other in the
playground and they think it's normal as
a consequence I think it really affected
my self-esteem and my confidence and at
its lowest point it led to depression
yeah and started watching porn aged just
ate its effects have been long-term
there was a lot of shame around there
made me feel really bad about myself in
the end I had to get help for it had to
get therapy and Yan's experience is now
more common than ever the government
says they are introducing tougher laws
forcing online providers
to make sure porn is only available to
over a teens but they've stopped short
of making sex education that tackles
porn and healthy relationships
compulsory some say changing that is the
only answer have washed Sky News